- Did y'all all meet?
Like when did you all meet?
Obviously not the first time
you did the show, right?
Like.
- Mixed.
- Mix.
First time I met Sheryl
was at a, an event,
an AIDS event to,
I think it was Broadway
Cares, but out here.
And you were sitting at my table
and the first thing you did
was introduce me to your husband.
I was like, "Oh, Sheryl
Ralph, I'm such a fan."
And she said, "Have you met my husband?
(audience laughing)
Senator Hughes?"
- Thank you.
- And I said,
"This woman's gonna stay
married a long time."
(laughing)
- She's a fan of him.
- [Lisa] That was smart.
- Yeah.
- [Lisa] But I never met
Quinta-
- The first time I met Lisa was on set-
- Yep.
- for the pilot.
She-
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And it was, she, you know,
auditioned for the pilot.
So I met her via that
and kind of first,
our first table read, which was over Zoom.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But the first time was
really doing the show.
I was just a fan of her and
a fan of her comedic career.
So-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was just like honored to,
to be talking to her.
(audience cheering)
And then-
- When did y'all first meet?
- The first time I met Quinta.
The first time I actually met Quinta
was on, this, one of the CBS lots.
- [Quinta] Yeah, oh-
- Oh my god.
- [Quinta] Okay, I didn't know if you
- [Sheryl] And you-
- [Quinta] were gonna say
that.
- [Sheryl] Yeah.
The CBS lots.
- [Quinta] Okay, yes, yep.
- And you had just sold one-
- I sold.
- One of your first shows.
- Yes.
- And my daughter and I
were walking across the lot
and my daughter, Coco, says,
"Mommy, that's Quinta Brunson
and she's gonna be big.
You have to meet her."
(audience clapping)
- She did.
- She was right.
- Coco did like-
- [Kelly] She called it.
- Yeah, she called it.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Sheryl] Yup.
- I, they probably caught this on camera,
but when you open your mouth to speak,
like you have one of
the most beautiful like,
singing voices obviously,
but talking voices-
- [Quinta] Oh yeah.
- And like one of the most-
- [Sheryl] Thank you.
- [Kelly] Recognizable, like,
I just, so many memories.
It's just this trip with nostalgia,
like listening to you.
- [Sheryl] Aw, thank you.
- Just when you started
talking, I was like
"I have no idea what you just said."
(laughing)
'Cause I was just,
I literally, I, I literally-
- [Lisa] Yes.
- [Kelly] Went to a place
like, that I was like-
- [Lisa] Yes.
"Oh my God, your voice
is just magical."
- Kelly.
- [Sheryl] Thank you.
- Kelly, she hypnotizes you.
- It does.
- [Lisa] That is what happens.
- [Quinta] It happens to me
all the time.
- I'll sit next door
in a scene,
and she, when she goes into-
- Yes.
- [Quinta] It happens to me.
- And I just am like-
(audience laughing)
- [Quinta] The same thing
happens to me.
- My eyes turn into spirals.
(audience laughing)
- And she'll be telling
me, and Sheryl will tell me
a story that will be the
most ridiculous story.
(laughing)
It will be ridiculous and funny.
But by the end I'm like,
"I'm sorry, what did you
say, I was, you were.
(laughing)
What are you talking about?"
- You know, it's
interesting, your tones
that come out of your,
it's the vibrations from-
- [Quinta] Yeah.
- It's just like so magical,
and I just, really, sorry,
I didn't hear damn a word.
(audience laughing)
I was like.
- Sometimes when I'm at
the airport, you know,
you know very often at the airport,
people are working with their heads down,
and you know, sometimes
they've had a hard day
and they wanna give attitude
and they'll say something.
And I'll say something like,
"I'm sorry, what did you say?"
And they'll look up and they'll say,
"Oh, Ms. Ralph, how are you?"
- No, literally,
it's so recognizable.
- [Sheryl] Yeah. Thank you.
- You can't go anywhere.
- Unless you're disguising
your voice.
Like, it's crazy cool.
- [Sheryl] Thank you.
- I just didn't even realize
that was gonna hit me like that
until in person and I'm
just having a moment.
- [Quinta] I love that.
- I'm having a moment.
I, 'cause, it's so funny
'cause I'm a singer,
but I can't stand my talking voice.
(laughing)
I don't leave,
I haven't left a voicemail
since like the nineties.
- [Quinta] I love your voice.
- Y'all love her
speaking voice?
- I was gonna say.
(audience cheering)
- [Kelly] No, you don't.
- [Sheryl] Yes.
- [Lisa] Yes.
- [Kelly] All lies.
- [Quinta] Kelly.
- [Lisa] America loves your
speaking voice.
- You have gotten me
to buy so much Wayfair.
(laughing)
My entire home.
That's all because of you.
It's all because of you.
- Oh my God. I'm telling
you, I can't listen.
I can't listen my speaking, anymore,
but yours is-
- [Sheryl] Thank you.
- Wah.
It's like a whole thing.
I'm lost right now.
I'm gonna get back on track. Okay.